foreign
are totally in love and enamored with my
husband and I just feel invisible he is
extroverted handsome and outgoing smart
funny and I'm none of those things I
call bullcrap on a stick you are not
telling the truth
[Music]
what's up this is John with the Dr John
deloney show
dancing like we've never danced before
on the greatest mental health and
relationship and parenting podcast ever
recorded
so glad that you joined us don't forget
to leave your five star reviews if you
got three star reviews give them to your
mom just get I don't know if your mom
has a podcast don't do that that would
mess up Thanksgiving
um but please leave your five star
reviews and please let folks
um sit on the show if you think man they
really need to hear this episode send it
to them even though it's going to be
weird send it their way and one way you
can really help out the show with no
money no anything just subscribing so
thank you so so much dude we have a
packed gang out here man it's good to
see everybody
um is this is going to be awkward for
everyone today so it's good to see y'all
all right let's go to Ryan in Arlington
Virginia what's up Ryan
hey Dr John how are you today I'm good
brother what are you up to man
oh not much a little nervous a little
nervous
I promise I'm more nervous than you
hey um so I got a question for you
um
that question would be
communication skills I'm just gonna get
right to it I have a question and that
question would be all right go ahead hey
we're in it together man what's up uh
all right so my communication skills are
just horrible
um you don't say you don't say I don't
say yeah
um and it's I feel like it's interfering
with some of my marital life
um and then a little bit in personal
life this was like some family members
and stuff just I'm not I don't know I'm
not able to communicate my feelings that
great
um it's caused a lot of stress I think
in the marriage sometimes when my wife
um you know has something that's
bothering her I'm just I'm not really
there for her like I should be why
um all right let me let me put it this
way communication is a skill set right
it's something we learn and something
you practice and you get better at over
time and you have to have two people
that communicate right one you can't
just be one person dumping into this
endless bottomless pit okay right the
other side of is the way you're laying
it out for me is that you've got all the
you've got this singular Challenge and
it's causing problems all through your
life
but you're not doing the little things
like communicating
right so what is not communicating
getting you because it gets you
something
um I I feel I feel safer not
communicating I guess um
what are things you wish you could
communicate that you're not
communicating
uh sometimes my own feelings uh my wife
she she's a little bit of an anxious
person too but
um I feel like sometimes communicating
my thoughts and feelings my
put a big load on her that I don't know
if she
you know is ready to handle or anything
like that so I want to dig into that but
let me say this anxiety is often a
function of disconnection and that's
some nerdy talk to say
if your wife knows something's going on
inside of you she feels that
and when you don't tell her or can't
tell her or shy away from the
conversation
her body starts sounding the alarms that
something's wrong
that something is probably wrong with
her
she needs to fix something so that the
relationship with you is okay and my
guess is that's a pattern that's been a
part of her life for a long long time
because we usually marry our own messes
and so I would suggest the opposite
truly saying what you need and what
you're thinking and what you're feeling
will potentially give her maybe at first
it'll spark it'll it'll it'll put some
oxygen on the fire will make it brighter
and a little bit taller but over time
that it will truly connect you to and
the anxiety will go down
see how this gets self-reinforcing
okay so what are the
what are the things that you're not
telling her what are your thoughts and
feelings that you're holding back
and let me say it this way you the only
way through this dude the way to
practice communication is being honest
and that's not your thing so do it here
yeah yeah yeah
um
say it say it say it
do it
um there are some things like when we we
got married fairly young into the
relationship so like three months of
dating we got married
um how old are you a year I'm 30. how
long y'all been married
six years okay
um
a year in their marriage
um we we had our first child and then
fast forwarding to now if we've got
three three child so ages five three and
one so a little a little bit of stress
with that type of stuff
um but but we love our kids they're
great
you liar you liar go ahead we do love
them we love them until they turn 18
then we'll be glad to see them go but
don't miss them right so
um I don't know I just have a hard time
expressing my thoughts and feelings
about things certain
certain things like maybe her like she's
real close to her family and a lot of my
values and beliefs don't really go
fully against like what her family sees
things and she it kind of puts her in
the middle of things
um and I feel like if I try to address
those situations then it puts her in a
hard spot to
try to pick between them or me do you
realize how you're treating her like
your daughter a little bit
you're not you're not giving her things
like this morning my family was is
we're meeting in Los Angeles but they
flew out this morning I'm gonna flew out
flat this afternoon and I my daughter
was trying to carry this big suitcase
and she couldn't carry it down the
stairs and so down into the basement
into the garage and so I carried it down
there for her because I'm her dad and I
got bigger muscles than she does and
that's what you're trying to do with
your wife
your wife's a grown woman she's married
mother of three I would guess she's a
gangster yeah and when you hold stuff
back from her because you're worried
that she can't
then you are you are making come true
what you're hoping isn't going to happen
which is a woman who feels trapped
between somebody who's not being honest
with her and treating her like a kid and
a group of people who are never honest
with her and who treat her like a kid
does that make sense it does
um go back to the beginning
you you
uh
y'all are married
but y'all don't have much of a marriage
do you
all run a daycare center together is
that fair that's very fair okay
your marriage is in desperate need of
y'all two dating each other
because you if you you're desperately
close to I can hear it in you're
desperately close
to turning into roommates if you're not
already or co-workers who in a factory
that makes children
and if you haven't already you are a
spider's web away from Finding Love
somewhere else
and she is too
that doesn't mean you're going to sleep
with somebody else but that means you're
going to become a workaholic that means
you're going to become just that Dad who
just kind of disappears or that Dad who
yells at
middle schoolers who are roughing soccer
games
and she's gonna disappear on you too
is that is that fair
yeah yeah that's fair are you already
there
pretty close
uh yeah I think I think we're pretty
close I mean she's told me multiple
times that she just
that she would like to be able to sit
down and talk with me but like I just
don't talk back like I'm just
emotionally not available why do you do
that to her why do you do that to you
and I know asking the why question is
something you're not supposed to ask in
counseling but we're not in accounting
sessions I'm just going to be direct
like why
why do you shut down
foreign
I get really uncomfortable just trying
to you know talk with people about my
feelings and I like it I don't know like
it doesn't matter or I'm not sure to to
what extent but I just who taught you
that
great pair
I was the middle child so you can take
that for what it's worth
um
mom was a little bit anxious but she you
know she supported us and dad was always
real supportive
um I I was always a real shy kid okay
and
um you know I just
was homeschooled up till you know sixth
or seventh grade something like that had
good
friends with the family and who did some
homeschooling as well then went to
public school and I think going into
public school I just
I was always kind of a smaller guy
um height wise and you know pretty thin
and hearing a lot of comments about that
from like other people sure
um around that age it just made me feel
like a ant in the world yeah
um
so so maybe I mean without without I
mean you and I man we could have 50
different sessions together and hang out
for a while and kind of mine it let's
just take that one that one seems
plausible enough in this short time that
we have together
um you learned really early on from
middle school on you should probably
disappear
or getting small is the best way to get
to navigate tough situations you avoid
ridicule you have what people make up
fun of you you avoid feeling less than
like a loser
just disappear and now you're sitting
across the table from your wife and
mother of your three kids
and there's nowhere to hide
does that make sense yeah yeah it does
so you've heard me say this a million
times on the show the thing that kept
you safe as a kid is now the thing that
is
setting your marriage on fire and it's
setting your parenting ability on fire
because you're passing this along to
your kids too and if you remember that
feeling of feeling small and feeling not
worth your space and feeling like I need
to hide from myself
so that I can avoid detection you don't
want your kids walking through life with
that either and it doesn't start with
you teaching them how to do it it starts
with you doing it standing up taller
speaking and being heard and thinking my
thoughts and my feelings are worth being
heard even when they're hard even when
they're going to cause problems because
right now you're causing problems
right and it feels safe it's kind of
like uh
uh it's like holding your breath on a
roller coaster it feels safe and
eventually you pass out and die
you got to breathe right so at some
point you have this conversation you're
either going to have it around a kitchen
table where you're being honest and open
or you're going to have it with a
divorce attorney
this conversation's coming
or multiple conversations are coming and
so here's my recommendation to you
um
hey let me let me back out a little bit
I've come at you a little bit
I know this is hard
and the reason I'm coming at you is I
just want to shake the snow globe a
little bit and move that sediment from
the bottom
it let you hear me
tell you you are worth being heard
and the best way to help your wife is to
be honest with her the best way to heal
yourself is to be honest with you and
you could have had the best parents on
the planet
and still they say little things like
you're not hurt
you're fine I know you want to eat here
but your brother's whining all the times
we're just gonna eat here I know you
want to play I know you made All-Star
team but we got to get your sister over
to this thing and so you just learn from
a young age that I matter a little bit
less than everybody else
and
that's going to be the end of you and
your marriage and so let's turn that
sucker around will you commit to that
yeah absolutely okay here is the way I
have navigated this in my life is when I
have to have the thoughts and feelings
conversation especially early on now
it's it's not a thing but especially
early on when I was learning this skill
um I say early on like five years ago so
not not very long ago is I wrote it all
down and there was multiple times my
wife and I read to her while we were
sitting down talking
because I didn't want to miss anything I
didn't want to get loud I didn't want to
get too quiet I didn't want to just be
weird or stumble through so I just wrote
it down and I read it
here is what I'm feeling here's what I
think
here's what I need if you start with
just those three things here's what I
feel here's what I think here's what I
need that's a great place to start
okay and then tell your wife we're gonna
send the kids away you you find the
babysitter not her okay you find the
babysitter and say hey and we're going
to spend a couple hours together because
I love you and I think it's fair to use
the language we run a daycare and I'm
interested in being married
and y'all gonna have to date each other
again man you all know y'all never
really dated yeah yeah and I
when's the last time y'all got away and
just had a barn burner romantic weekend
where you couldn't find clothes and the
wallpaper peeled off the hotel room
when's the last time
uh it's it's been probably at least a
year okay
you're worth that for whatever it's
worth
you're also work worth quiet walks in
the woods man like just getting away
doing whatever it is y'all do I'm just
saying man y'all
you'll have to create a life where you
all can be married and then the kids
come in after that not the other way
around
right cool are you in
I mean yeah okay
um start this conversation this way I'm
sorry for being quiet I learned at a
young age to be quiet and I promise to
start being more honest with you start
like that okay
okay and your wife will probably say
where's my husband what'd you do with
him thank you
if this goes terrible and it just goes
like horribly awry holler at me and I
will announce to the world that I failed
you
um but I think if you spend some time
being honest with yourself and writing
stuff down for the first time and then
you read that letter to her and you've
done the hard work of getting
babysitters clearing the deck so that
you all can have these conversations and
then you say hey I've already got us a
hotel room or I've already got us a date
night and we're gonna start putting on
the calendar
um you start down that road that way and
um
I'm convinced things will turn around
for you thank you for being honest my
man you are among millions of men just
like you trying to figure out what to do
um to help their wives be okay
and it often starts with us just being
honest for the very first time we'll be
right back
Dr John deloney here hey it's pumpkin
spice latte season
just kidding it's disgusting but it is
fall it's a little cooler the sun's
going down earlier and God save us
daylight savings time is ending or
starting or whatever the time is
changing again and it can be exhausting
to adjust but make sure you're moving
your body every day getting some
sunlight and getting seven to nine hours
of good sleep each night I can't stress
enough how important this is sleep is
the Cornerstone to physical and mental
health and for me great sleep starts
with a great mattress and that's why I
love dream cloud and right now dream
cloud is running a great offer for our
listeners 599 dollars in accessories
plus an additional 250 Dollar Cash
discount that's a total of eight hundred
and forty nine dollars in accessories
and savings you'll get pillows a
mattress protector and luxury sheets so
go to dreamcloudsleep.com deloney or
dreamcloudsleep.com and enter promo code
deloni to get your new mattress to day
all right hey we are back hey uh two
things one
I've got a
I've worn the first shirt with color on
it in like two years
and yes if you notice I bought two
killer shirts at the show that's how
good they were too I bought two of their
shirts I want to support Brandon Flowers
kids go to college fund and the second
thing is I've got this kombucha drink
and Kelly said it looks like I drained a
local sewer system and I'm drinking that
so I'm putting it on the floor so that
you YouTube the YouTube Community
doesn't get sick to your stomach is that
better
to start you're in there with your
kleenexes and super spreader event
behind there allergy
allergy that's what they all say that's
what they all say allergies
agree to disagree all right let's go to
Kim and Phoenix what's up Kim
hey good morning good morning
what are you up to
um working oh don't do that
I know but it's Friday yay way to go
what's up
hey um so my question is I have a son
who he's an adult
um about 27 and he is really overweight
um and I'm concerned about his
well-being not only
his his weight but also I think it's
just a symptom of a depression for him
and I don't really know how to talk to
him about it without alienating him or
feeling like he's being judged
um
and I I really I just I want to help
them I but I realize he's not a little
boy anymore and I can't but you know I
can't just throw him in the car and take
him to the doctor
um
how long has he struggle with his weight
a kid but he he was always like a big
boy right so always like Stout
um I'd say
so the weight really just kind of
compounded probably within the last 10
years or so okay what um
what in the environment
or let me just cut to the chase have you
struggled with your weight
um his dad struggled his weight other
people in the family
um I mean yes but not
like not like he has I mean was there a
culture of dieting was everybody on a
diet back in the day
um well yes okay okay
um nothing to feel shame about there I'm
just trying to get a context here
um Okay so
when it comes to obesity there's so much
there I can look at the data that says
that a number of obese there's a
correlation or uh I'll say not causable
but correlation between childhood abuse
and obesity there is genetics and
obesity there is environmental in
obesity right there's so many different
things and so anytime I'm on the
internet and somebody on Instagram's
like here's the deal I was like whatever
man and then there's also the
biomechanics
there's there's uh energy expenditure
right
you take in uh more than you I mean less
than you use then you lose weight and
you take it more than you use and you
gain weight so it's the whole picture is
Big
um no no pun intended there
um the whole picture is just it's vast
right and so
um here's what I did I I got a note from
Jenna that this was that you were
calling and so I actually called a
friend who's
done some extraordinary work
um is down a whole bunch of weight
really impressive actually motivated me
to get my butt back in the gym in a way
that was useful and
um so I asked him hey how would you like
to have had this conversation
um
and he gave me some really helpful
insights that were that were
different than what I thought quite
honestly so before I kind of write all
those off walk me through how other
conversations similar have gone with you
and him
having a conversation with him
specifically about his weight what about
what about others there's something
about you having a hard conversation
where you tell them you love him and
that you don't think is going to go well
because he shuts down and then he he
tends to ghost me
um
[Music]
here's where I'm here's where I'm
stutter stepping is I want to ask you
his mom some relationship questions but
you have to promise me you're not gonna
hang up the phone and beat yourself up
and be all and feel guilty and all that
I want to be more about let's get to the
solution focused part of this thing
um but often when I ask Moms especially
hard questions and sometimes dads it
just turns into a shame Factory and I
don't want to do that is that okay
oh yeah that's fine okay I'm good do you
all have a history of you telling him
about his you know what you need to do
you need to because that often causes
the shutdown
I do okay yeah
okay give me an example of a thing
you've got after him about and then he
just shuts it down
um well so a couple weeks ago we
and
um we had a nice lunch together and we
talked and
he had opened up about some of the way
that he was feeling and um I suggested I
made some suggestions of him just you
know taking some small steps and hey I
joined the gym that's really close to
where you live and if you would like to
meet me there after work I'd love to
walk with you or hell even put you on my
gym membership but you just need to do
something like every day and and get up
and you know go do that and so yeah you
know he's and he's been on other diets
before like
going spending money on like weight loss
um centers and going and he's had some
luck but I admit you know we've been a
little negative about that because we
just didn't think it was the right
approach or sustainable
um so I mean I feel guilty about that
because it should have just supported
him in whatever but I
um
so so so I agree with you I agree with
you
um
foreign
hey I've recognized I've put on a lot of
weight I'm not healthy anymore and again
let's get away from the
um the body positivities I'm talking
about just Health he's not healthy he
doesn't feel good and he knows it and
you know everybody knows it
um if he comes to you and says hey
what's the best plan do you think for me
what's the best plan for you
um then that's an invitation to say well
here's what I've seen be successful
here's what I've tried a couple of times
it hasn't worked when you launch
missiles at him uh well here's what you
need to be doing
yes that is I mean all you can do is put
up your force field right you put up
your defense shields
and he's learned that over his entire
life and my guess is he's seen Mom and
or dad on diets for most of their life
and he's seen them be miserable
and I don't want any part of that and I
don't want any part of my
um increasing
um unhealthy behaviors
and the only solution I have for that
being stuck in the middle there is to
eat
see what I'm saying see how he's trapped
yeah okay so here's the here's what I
would do in this situation and I'm gonna
start it with this
um
I saw a clip years ago it might have
been 10 years ago and it has resonated
with me just stuck with me it was pin or
teller do you all know which one pin or
teller the tall one
that's uh pen pin that's all yeah all
right so pin um just had like was
talking into a cell phone this is before
Instagram it was all pretty and slick
and everything it was just him and this
the phone was too close to his face I
remember and here's what he said uh pin
is a is a is a very vocal atheist and
um
but all accounts are really kind human
being just a very vocal atheist and he
said after a show
um he's recording this right after this
interaction after a show some fans came
and they were talking about you know the
show and how much they liked it and then
one fan in particular was very
knowledgeable about magic was mesmerized
by the interaction was really talk like
he said this guy knew what he was
talking about and I loved the
interaction with him he clearly loved
the show and he clearly was moved by our
performance and how much fun it was and
all that stuff and then he said as the
guy was leaving he turned and said hey I
I know your beliefs and thoughts I just
can't walk away without letting you know
I'd love for you to come to church with
me tomorrow or the next whenever it was
and
um it'd be awesome you'd be my guest and
they shook hands and he left and here's
what Penn said he said if you ever want
to try to convict somebody that's how
you do it
through relationship through genuine
conversation and he said that man
um he said if if a truck is driving down
the street and you're in the middle of
the street
you have to push the guy out of the way
and he said after talking with that man
for a while
he believes I'm in the middle of a
street and a truck is barreling down on
me and he wants me to be okay forever
and he says I disagree with him I don't
believe what he's saying but man I
really am grateful for the way he
reached out to try to love me a little
bit better
and so I tell you that to tell you he
didn't walk around and hold signs in
front of the show
he didn't lob grenades throughout the
show
he went up and shook his hand and said
you're amazing at your craft can we talk
craft for a minute because I want to be
a magician too and by the way I need you
to know I love you do you see the
difference there
yes okay so I'm a huge fan of if you
love somebody you have the hard
conversation I'm also a big fan of if
you think somebody is In Harm's Way you
tell them
I'm also a big fan of whenever possible
do it out of relationship and you might
have to submit to the fact that you
might not be the right person to have
this conversation
there might be too much baggage in the
past so here's how I would approach this
if I were you and this is my kid number
one I would probably have some sort of
lunch meeting again and say I have
absolutely blown this whole thing and
I'm sorry I screwed this up I'm always
lecturing you treating you like you're
12 and you're a grown adult and I'm
sorry I love you and I don't know how to
do this but it's the first time I've had
a son like this so I don't know how to
do it and I just want you to know I'm
sorry I should have supported you I
should have been all behind who wants to
go work out with her mom
uh nobody nobody
um so just just just lay it out and he
might be stunned this might be so
opposite of the way you normally
interact in the world
um you might have to practice this a few
times but just tell him
um there is not a thing on Earth you can
do that will make me love you less
period
and then let him know this
when and if you ever want to have this
conversation with me I'm willing to put
money on the table I'm going to be
supportive and keep my mouth shut I'm
going to love you but I want you to know
I'm worried about your health and I love
you forever to the Moon and back
and then here's part two
um my friend told me that yes his mom's
had conversations with him for years but
it was actually a mentor it was a buddy
that reached out out of the blue and had
um invited him into a solution
said hey I just want you to know this is
a hard conversation and I'm just I don't
want to be weird but I want you to know
that I love you and I'm worried about
you and that combined with Mom's support
um was a game changer
and it reminded me when he was telling
me of this when I was in the throes of
being anxious like a crazy person
my wife actually reached out to my
friend Todd
who is a banker a stogo I've talked
about him on the show
um he's the one who drove down and met
with me and walked around my house when
I was showing him how the house was
falling in and he's the one that said
stop
we're done with all of this you got to
get the help
and because I couldn't hear it from
myself anymore I couldn't hear it from
my wife anymore I couldn't hear it from
my parents anymore
but listening to Todd that was the first
time I looked in the mirror and said it
may be me I need to go talk to somebody
and so if he has a friend if he has a
male Mentor if he's got some men in his
life that he trusts and you want to do
an end around and call one of them and
say hey would you mind reaching out and
just tell them that you love him that
you're worried about him
um I think that would go a long long way
what do you think about all that
I think it's
um
I think it's wise advice like
um how old is he
he's 27. okay can we admit something
the way you've done it up till now
hasn't worked
because I hear the hesitancy will you
try something else
yes yes okay
I promise you that nobody on Earth knows
that he's overweight more than he does
is that true
foreign
yeah
so let's be with not at right now
okay
okay
tell me why you're crying
you just worry yeah
because you love him
yes
foreign
and this happens at the at the at the
national level
happens at the state level happens the
neighborhood level happens in our homes
happens in our marriages happens with
our kids
sometimes we love so much and we're out
of we're out of uh
we're out of tools
all we have in our in our bag is a
hammer
so instead of we're just hit start
hitting the nail hitting the nail and
hitting the nail and it's not moving and
so we just start wailing at it because
oh we only know one thing to do and
that's just to swing the hammer harder
instead of putting the hammer down and
saying okay that's not working I need to
go think on something else
I don't know you love him I know you
love him a lot
let's focus on being with not at let's
focus on getting some people that he
listens to in his life and that means
you have to admit that it may not be you
let's get some people in his life and
let's be about forgiving yourself
again I don't want you hanging up the
phone and beating yourself up Kim okay
we do the best we can because we love
our kids
and it's also important when we realize
I need to call somebody else
let him know from this point forward
I'm not gonna throw a bunch of advice at
you I'm not going to throw all my diet
books and my apps and my gym memberships
at you
you don't have to put on leg warmers and
come work out with your mom with your
mom
I'm worried about you and I love you and
I will be in your corner
fortunately sometimes that's the best we
can do
thank you for loving him we'll be right
back
hey deloney here and I've got a word
from our sponsor from betterhelp I've
been on the giving and receiving end of
therapy for years when I was spinning
out like a decade ago with wild anxiety
I had a moment that light bulb moment
that I knew I had to do something
different I knew I had to change
something probably a lot of some things
right but I found myself without the
tools for taking the next step
when you're facing problems or
challenges in life it's way too easy to
get stuck in that anxious spiral of Doom
I've been there but when you learn how
to stop that cycle and start taking
ownership of your life that's when
you're free
and that's what therapy can help you do
it gives you the tools you need to do
the problem solving in your own life and
that's why I love Better Health
betterhelp is online therapy that offers
video phone and even live chat sessions
with your therapist it's more affordable
than in-person therapy plus you can be
matched with a therapist in under 48
hours if you're ready to get the tools
that you need to deal with the
curveballs life's thrown at you therapy
can help visit betterhelp.com deloni to
get 10 off your first month that's
betterhelp.com deloney
all right we are back let's go to uh
let's see
Raleigh North Carolina and let's talk to
Grace what's up Grace
Hi how are you good how are you
rocking on some breakdown yes
very cool
all right well I'll dive into my
question if I had t-shirts you would get
one I don't have one but that was
awesome not yet not yet actually I'm
they're at the printer right now so
they're coming so what's up
well I need some help feeling like I
belong in my own home
why don't you feel like you belong in
your own home
well I feel like my kids
we are totally in love and enamored with
my husband as am I and I just feel
invisible like
not even there
which makes me withdraw even more and um
furthers the problem
so
why are you jealous of your husband what
does he do that you think you can't or
don't do
we are total opposites we grew up on the
opposite ends of the planet
um he is extroverted handsome and
outgoing smart funny
talented
has a million friends
um successful and I none of those things
I call bullcrap on a stick in a box
on the wings of an eagle Grace you are
not telling the truth you are none of
those things you're not beautiful smart
fun kind engaging yes you are
well it doesn't feel that way sometimes
okay that'll buy but I won't buy that
none of that's true
um where does that story come from
um I guess that's always kind of been
the story I've never really like
excelled in anything I've never been
super successful at anything you nabbed
an incredible life partner
exactly
kids what do you do for a living
I work as an admin part-time
so you keep the entire
one time uh I I was a part of
um an organization we had to make a a
lot like a million dollars worth of of
budget cuts and much of that was people
and on the way to uh my wife and I were
driving somewhere one day and my admin
at the time her name was Tracy she's one
of the most extraordinary people I've
ever met
and my wife turned on the radio and she
goes oh yeah I forgot to tell you and I
thought she was gonna tell me like um
that she got a new pair of shoes and she
goes oh yeah I forgot to tell you
um if you cut Tracy I'm Gonna Leave You
I was like why and she goes because our
whole life is better because she is in
your life and so I don't care who you
have to cut she stays and I was like I
was like you got it so as an admin you
help people's families stay together and
businesses run like what
there's a picture in your mind about the
way things should be and there is a
feeling in your heart about the way
things will feel when we get there
tell me about this picture that you have
what is what is Grace winning look like
I feel like
um no no no we'll get the feelings in a
second what does it look like okay
it looks like
um
me keeping a successful job for a long
period of time and contributing
to the home and being able to have
meaningful conversations with my kids
okay
um contributing to the home
that sounds like a like a something
somebody stencils onto a like a
I don't know shiplap that's pulled out
of an old home and then they sell it on
Pinterest what is contributing to the
home mean
you pay bills you buy the nice like what
does it mean
yeah it's a it's having to pay the bills
we're to and from school on time
um and right now he does the majority of
that okay and on top of all of his other
things that he has going on where are
where are you in the home why aren't you
taking some of that off uh why aren't
y'all sharing more of that
um I try but he you know the kids would
rather
dad take them to school and dad picked
them up from school and would rather be
around dad and so
I'm just home
why have you outsourced your feelings in
the operation of your home to
a couple of knuckleheaded kids
yeah I
think you've outsourced your entire
feelings to people that we as a society
said they can't even buy beer or guns or
cigarettes because they're kids
yeah they can't drive
because they're kids but you've
outsourced everything to them why
they're my whole world I want to be lost
Grace they can't be your whole world
because they throw temper tantrums and
they say mean things
and they talk back and they forget crap
and they steal and they lie because
they're kids and they're just trying to
test how the world works
okay
who told you you're worth so little
I guess nobody ever really told me I was
worth much that's fair
actually in the trauma literature
um that's been one of the revelations of
the last couple of decades is that
trauma can be somebody doing things to
you they shouldn't have trauma can also
be withholding things from you that they
should have given you
and whatever it's worth I'm sorry
can I ask you a question about Mr
Wonderful
uh-huh
my guess is he contributes to that
is that fair
um
yes and no tell me more he has he has a
lot going on I mean he don't I I don't
give a crap I could care less
does he contribute to that
because the things he's got going on are
things he's choosing to do
and if he's choosing a lot going on over
making sure his marriage is tightly
braided together with you
making sure that you come first and then
those knuckle-headed slobbery kids
making sure that you've got role and
purpose the same as he's got role and
purpose it's easy to be a rock star
it's hard to set the stage up and take
it down every day
is he contributing to this
because my guess is you've idolized
somebody that's not an idol
foreign
and you've demonized somebody who's not
a demon and now you've created an entire
fantasy world with which you can't live
in and that goes back to this I don't
feel like I belong in my own home
because you've created a Marvel
character that you share a bed with and
he's not he might be good looking and he
might be funny
he's not perfect
and if he's putting a kids above you
he's hurting his wife
and he's hurting his kids
and he's using his kids to prop up his
own fragile ego and I could go on and on
and on and on
okay
my question for you though is do you
want this to be different because this
has been a pattern for a long long time
in your life right
yes
do you want it to be different
absolutely how much so because it's
going to upturn the apple cart
I mean it's it's got to go a different
way I can't I can't keep going like this
awesome that I mean that's perfect that
that's somebody who knows this apple
cart is going to crash or we're going to
change directions right
something happened for you to call me
this is the moment hold on how long have
y'all been married
uh to be 16 years in December yep okay
um
how old are your kids
uh we have a 15 year old and a 12 year
old okay
[Music]
you've either thought about leaving
you have somebody that you kind of have
a crush on
or he does
no not even
positive
absolutely okay so why the call now
um I think I've been struggling a lot
with depression and it's that's honestly
what it sounds okay that's honestly what
it sounds like and here's the deal I was
pushing on him a little bit
Oz prodden the same as I just said I
think you've got somebody you might not
okay or I trust you that you don't
um he might have been over time picking
up the extra slack because he's trying
to love you the best he can
and if you're getting a little lower and
a little lower and he's picking up a
little more slack and a little more
slack you see how that's
self-reinforcing
think of it this way that's exactly you
ever um you ever and if I talk to him
he'd be like dude man my wife's
struggling I'm trying to give her a
break
um and so if you think about going to
the gym you ever I don't know if you
ever lifted weights have you ever seen
been to the gym and they got spotters
um
if somebody keeps struggling with the
weight and the spotter
keeps helping more and more and more
over time those workouts become
completely unhelpful
and the person who's getting stronger is
actually the spotter not the person
who's just having their weight supported
with by somebody else's work and so the
unfortunate thing is when you start
getting lower and lower the path out is
to systematically participate a little
bit more and more little wins
all right
okay
you have to commit to decoupling
yourself from how you feel and reality
because your feelings aren't telling you
the truth anymore
okay okay is that do you believe that
yes
um I keep this you if you're watching on
YouTube I keep this little thing with me
at all times I write notes in it during
the show I write notes in it while I'm
driving which I shouldn't do I write
notes while I'm hunting I keep this
thing with me all the time
for this very reason
you suck at being a dad
sometimes I'll write that down and I'll
look at it and then I can say is this
true I demand evidence from those
feelings
or I feel really sad
or I feel really heartbroken and I write
that down and it's true and I feel it
and I own it and then I go about what I
got to do next
and it feels like over time
your feelings have taken off and they
are now in control
and we have to put them back in the back
seat they are very important
participants in this ride we're on
but if we let them drive we end up in a
mess we end up out in the woods
somewhere instead of on the road okay
okay how do you talk to a counselor a
professional
no I'm trying to find one now okay
um I'll hook you up with a few months uh
with better help if you will commit to
doing that
absolutely that takes away your excuse
because they they can do it via Zoom is
that cool
yep okay
here's what I want you to start
personally though
I want you to spend some time I want you
to go to Walmart or some place you can
get on Amazon's order and have it
shipped to your house tomorrow
but I want you to get a journal of some
sort and begin to sort through here's
what I feel
have you ever sat down and said your
feelings out loud to your husband
um sometimes okay do you trust him
absolutely okay awesome so maybe do a
true or false test
I'm gonna rattle off 15 feelings will
you just say true or false that's it
that's all you get to say true or false
I am a burden in my own home he's gonna
say false
I am not funny I am ugly I am nobody
wants to hang out with me he's going to
say false false false
and we're gonna go down that list okay
when my feelings get very strong I
actually Outsource them
I've got a couple of people at work I've
got a couple of long-term friends that I
say hey I feel like this am I crazy and
they speak truth to me because I don't
see it my feelings are loud inside my
body and I know myself well enough to
know that now
um and I want you to begin to talk to
somebody and my promise to you is if
you'll commit to this the lights will
come on
they'll be very dim at first but they'll
come on it's also going to require you
to do some things a little bit different
like
I'm taking the kids to school three days
a week now
whether they kick or scream or what I
don't care I'm gonna take them and you
might have to you know what hey stay on
the line also uh Jenna let's get her all
the questions for humans cards
we're going to give you some tools to
talk to your kids while you're in the
car with them because now it feels weird
right you feel like you're taxing around
people who don't like you
exactly they do
it's just they're responding to your
weird by being weird and then you're
responding to their weird which they're
15 and 12 they're weird trust me
um if they're wearing new underwear
they're still weird right
um
I want you to begin to lean into uh
I suck when I said they wear new
underwear 15 and 12 year olds sometimes
shower and they put the same underwear
back on
if you've ever been to like uh camp or
something with kids it's disgusting
because they just are like well I gotta
change underwear why it's all fun that's
what I'm talking about
um
but you see how you're Outsourcing your
feelings to them so here's what we're
gonna do we're going to be the adult and
we're going to start practicing entering
square into their space
away I do this now is I my 12 year old
son and I uh we go to breakfast every
week at Waffle House
the uh the uh healthiest place on Earth
we love it
um my daughter and I a couple of nights
a week she is she is fused to my wife
and if I ask her hey uh can I do bedtime
tonight and read your stories
no Mom
and so two or three nights a week a
couple nights a week
um she doesn't get an option Dad's doing
bedtime tonight you can have nobody or
you can choose that
and if I trust me I feel like a like am
I so bad that my daughter won't let me
read her story like what but I also know
that she's six and she doesn't get a
vote into my innermost uh feelings
because she's six
is that fair
absolutely okay
hear me say this
you're worth being well
and you're worth a marriage it's
incredible that you feel an equal part
of and
you and your husband and your kids need
you
to firmly plant your feet in your home
and say this is my home too
you can't earn your way to that it has
to be an identity that you act your way
out of
I am going to fill in the blank because
this is my house
I'm going to turn my dance music on and
we're gonna dance
because this is my house
tonight we're having this because it's
my house
I'm doing bedtimes tonight I'm taking
the kids to school because I'm going to
participate in the life of my home
because this is my life too does that
sound good
yeah
you sound like you don't believe me yeah
I'm sorry I'm just trying to process no
it's a lot it's a lot is this exciting
or no or does it just feel overwhelming
it feels very overwhelming how come
um
I don't even know
I feel like I've lived too much time and
now it's going to be too late by the
time I turn it around all right you just
said it perfectly
I feel like I've wasted too much time
and it's going to be too late
I want you to write that one down
and I want you to hold it at arm's
length and be objective
have you truly wasted too much time
as a guy who's seen a number of adult uh
parent-child relationships change
dramatically into some extraordinary
relationships
the answer is no
you haven't waited too long
is it too late absolutely not
do you need to learn some new skills for
sure
do you need to learn a regular practice
of challenging those feelings absolutely
it's about a set of skills not that
you're a bad mom
it's about a set of skills not that
you're a bad wife
is that true
you're right
Grace I know that so that's that's all
right fine you're right okay
you can't quit this conversation
okay well okay fine fine we'll just uh
we'll just do whatever you all want to
do that's cool
now tonight we're having Burgers because
I'm freaking Grace and I want burgers
laughs
okay see what I'm saying
now as soon as we get off the phone
you're gonna be go and go right back to
where where you're feeling
that's why I'm going to send you these
tools
um I'm also going to send you on your
pass change your future I'll send you
the book too I'm gonna send you
everything I got okay
great thank you okay
um please though at the top of the list
get a journal
and right after that
I want you to make sure you plug in with
a professional counselor because I do
think you're running pretty low and I
think it's been that way for a long time
Fair
yes okay let's get with somebody who's
gonna walk with you on a you know every
other day or a weekly basis for a while
and
um help untangle some of this stuff
my promise is if you will put the work
in even when you're tired and it feels
futile right now it feels like it's it's
too too too too far gone
there's light on the other side of this
I've seen it
and you can see it too
be right back
it seems so easy but most of us way
undervalue real genuine relationships
our friendships our marriages we don't
know what we're doing and instead of
diving into the mess we accept
shallowness and distraction and we
wallpaper over our loneliness so let me
say this boldly you cannot be well alone
you've got to get connected to real life
people and have deep powerful
relationships I'm talking about
relationships where you can be honest
where you can open up where you can
share hard things and you each know that
you'll still show up for each other and
in my new book own your past change your
future we'll walk through a not so
complicated approach to relationships
mental health and wellness and getting
connected is a key part of that that's
why you'll learn shallowness and
loneliness are so dangerous and more
importantly you'll learn how to create
meaningful relationships in your life
moving forward there is no good app to
help adults find friendships but this
book can help go to John deloney.com to
take the next step towards Wellness
that's own your past change your future
at John deloney.com
all right as we wrap up today's show hey
I want to take a quick quick minute I
want to dedicate this show to my cousin
James who passed away this weekend and
uh
man
had a lot of demons and was one of the
most Brilliant Minds I've ever been
around and my favorite thing about James
was that uh how much he loved his kids
how much he loved the people around him
and that every single time I was around
him he pulled me aside
said I'm proud of you keep doing what
you're doing
so we'll miss you my man we'll miss you
um and to all family man
uh we'll rally around one another as we
always do
song of the day in honor of me going to
California this afternoon is from the
great Led Zeppelin song called going to
California and it goes like this spent
my days with a woman unkind smoked my
stuff and drank all my wine made up my
mind to start a news to make a new start
going to California with an aching in my
heart someone told me there's a girl out
there actually my wife will be there
that's kind of cool with love in her
eyes and Flowers in her hair she does
not have flowers in her hair my wife has
a mohawk she shaved it yesterday just
kidding she didn't but that would be
awesome took my chances on a big jet
plane to find a queen without a king
foreign
[Music]